does this mean that you've managed to
get out of the cave what do you mean
when you say you're living that myth
yeah okay so I feel like after I wrote
American Cosmic you know in the myth do
you know the
myth so my understanding of the cave
myth allegory whatever one wants to call
it is that there are a set of people and
they're tied up and they're looking at
the wall and on the wall are images
which are adumbrations because they're
Shadows from something else well we
don't know that they don't know that
they mistaken the wall the cave wall for
quote unquote reality until one gets
loose and then sees that these are mere
projections of something else and this
outside world is the true quote unquote
reality and then people have forgotten
about the third part which is that the
sun was too
blinding and they have to retreat into
the
darkness essentially that there exists
such a thing as too much truth
and also that they tell people and many
people consider them to be desate and
insensate much like right now with
people considering those who well if you
have any belief that is borderline quote
unquote woo then that's what one
is labeled as yeah so okay so this is
that's generally good good job okay so
there are two things though that I think
that we have to concentrate on when I
finished American Cosmic I was like kind
of obsessed with the ca the cave and so
I went back and I read different
versions of it you know translations and
everything which then I realized wait a
minute it's not actually an allegory and
wait a minute it's in a book about
politics and so I thought this is
strange and I also thought this I
thought who are the people that tie us
up you know because and I asked a lot of
my friends who happen to be philosophers
I said have you ever thought about the
people who tied us up in the cave and
they said oh oh no no no it's just an
allegory and I was like I don't think so
I think that people actually tied us off
and in fact because of my experience
with American Cosmic I believe that
people tied us up right and so I then
wanted to tell people yeah I think that
people tied us up I mean in the cave
people tied us up I know what I'm saying
is you believe now that people tied us
up or yeah are you indicating that the
extraterrestrials or whatever it me no
no no I think that we're doing it to
each other we're you know we're
misinforming each other like there's
obviously this misinformation campaign
that happened for UFOs let's just say
that happened we know it happened yeah
so people intentionally said this is
what's happening over here what you see
is real but all of a sudden we're like
whoa what I saw wasn't real and we and
so okay so I became kind of obsessed
with that and trying to get my friends
who are in philosophy to admit that
people tied us up and then I read it so
many times that I realized that I was
that person person who was basically
trying to convince people and that what
happens is you have to basically just
leave the cave and but there's something
at the end of the that uh the cave
allegory I'm just going to call an
allegory since people have called it
that but it's not um at the end that
person who escapes the cave and then
goes back and tries to tell people that
they're in the cave and then they don't
believe that person and then that person
spends a lot of time you know precious
time basically saying get out of the
cave come on I'll help you but they
don't and they think you're crazy and I
thought people think I'm crazy and I
said I'm just going to stop because
that's who I am in this right now in
this in this myth I am that crazy person
he's basically telling
people we got tied up everyone let's get
out of the cave well the next step is is
what my book is going to be about the
next step is the step of where that
person leaves the cave and then what
they do because they don't just leave
the cave Cur they actually engage in
something and Plato calls it a craft or
Socrates does Plato is the one who's
writing it but Socrates calls it a craft
not a not a a flying saucer craft a
craft right like a a way of
being that you engage in with
another and I think that's what I think
that's the heart of it and that's what
we've forgot like we've been kind of
hypnotized by the we are in a cave thing
and forgot really what he was trying to
tell us and so I'm going to go back and
and kind of um do a reading of that let
me recount it once more so they see the
Shadows guy or girl comes out notices
quote unquote reality comes back tries
to tell people and they don't believe
him or her then this person leaves to do
a
craft what is meant by that in the book
I mean sorry not in your book
necessarily if you don't want to give it
away but in the allegory quotequote
allegory yeah so that's the question
what is meant by that so that's I think
the the thing we need to ask so what
happens is that they go out of the cave
and then he's talking to I think it's
his brother right or his brother-in-law
or something so in the you know when
Plato recounts it Socrates is talking to
somebody and he basically says and
wouldn't it be the case that we engage
in this this dialogue or dialectic and
that this is a craft and that we this is
what we need to do it's almost like if
you want to know the answer for how to
stay out of the cave or the answer to
help you you
know to deal with the reality that we
live in is to engage in this craft and
that's what he's trying to tell us and
this happens to be in a book about
political
philosophy and I think that's really
important and I think that Iris
Murdoch's book called
um I think it's called the
good
um it's something to do with the good I
just read it but it's it's a excellent
um it's an excellent take on this I
think she gets it
right and the take
is that the good is to be
political uh no the good is to engage in
this type of um craft that that Plato
discusses and it's an answer to the
political because you know in this talk
you and I have been talking about
religion democracy secularism you know
we've been talking about these different
forms of government and stuff and Plato
is basically showing us something and
then haiger Believe It or Not goes back
and he tries to recreate that through
writing this philosophy where he
questions
everything and so he's basically doing
exactly the
craft although I don't think he actually
gets it as much as Iris Murdoch
does that so that's what's happening and
that's what our that's what our culture
right now we're stuck in the cave and we
just don't we just don't know how to get
out and I think that that's it because
it took me a I mean it took me a while
to figure it out myself like what is he
saying and then I had to read it you
know how you can read something so many
times and then finally you're like oh
that's what he's saying right sometimes
it takes a while to because we've been
so programmed to read it a certain way
but actually I don't think that's the
way it's meant to be read at all the way
that we've been reading
it I was watching a talk of John Veris
on heiger and John was saying in his
language so I'm going to use and this is
a bit esoteric but he was saying that
heiger was stating that the whole
process of metaphysics for the past
2,000 years is one of distancing we
distance ourselves from the as a subject
from the object and this is perhaps a
misframing and that we shouldn't be
seeking propositional answers but
instead participatory answers so that is
that it's a difficult I don't know how
to okay let me
think so a a dance is participatory so
there's a form of knowledge associated
with dancing that's not propositional
it's not writing and then it's not
logical per se 100% well that's
procedural as well so there's another
format so are you suggesting that
perhaps what's happened is that we've
gotten lost thinking that the by
elevating the propositional knowledge
and what we need to do is go back to the
participatory yeah and and that's
exactly what I'm saying I am exactly
saying that the way that we've read the
cave right has been a propositional
framework we've used a propositional
framework to read it and we've neglected
to see the most important point that is
trying to tell us and that we have to go
back
and look at that and really engage with
what it is that he that he told us back
in the day and I think that Hyer tried
to do that I don't I mean he he was
successful but I think that a lot of
people just don't even know understand
what haiger was doing and I think what
you just said was correct I think we
have to be participatory in that way
engage because the craft isn't engaging
it's a dialectic it's a dialogue and you
do it with a person and you know what I
find fascinating is that you also see
this in Buddhism so one there are these
these things called the three jewels of
Buddhism one is the Buddha not that you
worship this guy named the Buddha it's
actually a title which means awake and
Buddhism so you have Buddha as the as an
example of what a human being can become
they can become awake and then you have
the Dharma which is the teaching and it
doesn't have to be a book it's anything
that's going to wake you up that's the
teaching and then you have the most
important point the SA and that's the
community because human beings live
together we don't live as you know so we
have to do this together and I think
that that's what Socrates was basically
saying is saying they're all in the C
like we you know okay sad for them you
tried to get them out but now we have
each other and this is what we have to
do to keep each other from being put
back in the cave I mean he was saying
that and he demonstrated it in the book
is there an aspect of meaning associated
with this or rediscovering meaning yeah
it's a it's a meaning that's intrinsic
now here's the reason I say that is
because from my understanding of heiger
and heiger is one of the hardest people
to read yeah I agree he makes up his own
language but he was saying look what a
lover does as a if you love your spouse
you give them flowers you don't give
them plants you don't give
them subjects of of of Horticultural
investigations but they're the same
they're actually the same the plant and
the flower and the Horticultural
investigatory object is the same however
it's wrong to give your spouse a plant
for Valentine's Day and so it's because
even though the literal is the same the
meaning isn't and there's something
about recapturing meaning or looking at
something in the correct way that haiger
was pointing to one of the reasons I
like heiger is that in some sense
remember I was giving you an outline of
what theories of everything is MH now no
way am I saying it's a continuation of
hydro's project but it's it's similarly
themed in that he was suggesting that
the that a project should be that we
should be understanding our being in
order to understand our relationship to
being in order to understand being and
well what is being well being is I don't
know how to describe what heiger would
say being is other than existence and
earlier you mentioned that heiger was
interested in why something exists I
think that Vicken Stein was interested
in why something exists and how
something exists where heiger was
interested in existence what is
existence itself I agree with you I
think so I think also that Vicken Stein
realized that language actually couldn't
contain a lot of what existence is about
and then you know he kind of gave up on
it and he said I think his famous quote
is of that which we cannot speak we
should remain silent which I of course
don't agree with because then you have
art right and music so let's not remain
silent that would take away a good part
of what living is about so yeah well he
also was an artist he I don't know if he
meant language per se rather than art
maybe art was an was a was all right to
as a mode of expressing oneself to
understand the world it's it's strange
because I was looking up haiger and
heiger apparently was an atheist but I
see him as in a sense wrestling with God
or trying to figure out what God is and
same with viin
vicenin I don't think he explicitly
called himself an atheist but either way
Norman Malcolm I don't know if you know
this his friend Norman Malcolm said the
religiosity that characterized Vicken
Stein was greater than the average
religious person and viin he said he
can't help but see every problem through
a religious point of view so I see
haiger similarly where even though he
may say he's an atheist it seems like
what he's doing is is trying to
understand god well I mean there's a
reason why I'm very attracted to his
work and you know and I I find it to be
mystical I think that his later work was
he he had a mystical experience and they
tried to express that that understanding
through his and I think that's why he
went presocratic he went back to this
you know Socrates and presocratic in
order
to you know to express what he thought
we had lost as a culture have you heard
from many of the people who are on the
more Buddhist Eastern end that would say
that you cannot discover God or reality
or whatever
synonym want wants to give it that has
some dramatic flare to it you cannot
Discover it via an analytical approach
that you must experience it has to be
something that is beyond language do you
have firstly have you heard that and
then secondly if you have do you believe
that to be the case yes so I would say
that um Beyond haider's writing and Anna
Hana arents writing um I was very
influenced by the writings of the people
involved in What's called the Kyoto
school so the Kyoto school was a
Japanese school of Zen Buddhism
philosophers they didn't call themselves
religious religion wasn't even a a term
for them but they they were using Zen in
order to explicate like philosophy and
that's how Hyer kind of got involved
with them and um one of my one of the
books that I think is most fascinating I
think it's called um I think it's called
the philosophy of nothingness and I
forgot exactly who wrote it but it's
that person his he had that's where he
links he actually went back and read n
and kind of through the lens of Zen
Buddhism and I thought it was a
fascinating book um so if you're
interested it's the philosophy of
nothingness so yes absolutely that's
what he was basically saying I mean I
also think that n was a Mystic as well
you know his his his flashes is
basically
mysticism now n is someone that I feel
horrible for not liking because Everyone
likes everyone but I don't I I just
can't i' rather read what other people
have said about him than than go to the
primary source which is an athma to to
Scholars because it's well to me the way
that I view it it's like wine you you
for me when I drank which I I don't
drink anymore but I was never partial to
Wine to Wine I I I'll have some of it
but then there same with the stronger
drinks they don't taste good but I'm not
going to torture Myself by constantly
drinking it in order to get the quote
unquote in acquired taste so I think
that's what's necessary in order to
understand n properly no it's not did
did you not read about my n
synchronicity that caused because I
hated n yeah well that well good for you
in the sense that you're lucky that you
have that no I know because I would have
continued to hate Nicha as well just
like you and good for you I I would be
very suspicious of a person who
naturally liked n frankly I think you
have to encounter n
so yeah I mean a lot of what he says is
horrible so I'm much more of a
lovecraftian in the sense that you
mentioned the cave allegory and I'm much
more inclined to feel like that and I
used to be of the type that give me the
truth no matter what form it comes but
I've had some experiences where I feel
like sometimes the truth is far too much
for you to handle and you can you can
damage yourself drastically from an
encounter with the truth and Lovecraft
had this this quote which which to me I
interpret as the case for ignorance and
it's it's something like the greatest
Mercy in the world is the inability for
the human mind to correlate its contents
and that one day we'll see that this
unfettered scientific investigation may
bring about such a terrifying Vista of
reality that we'll see our fragile place
in it and be so frightened that we'll
either go mad from the Revelation or or
flee from the light into the peace and
security of the Dark
Ages so in the cave allegory I see that
as the person who runs back in the cave
now you mentioned that there may be a
solution to that and I well I'm I'm
praying and I'm hoping that your book
provide some solution to that because
right now I'm fleeing from the from
the from the light let's
say you mean you're going back into the
cave I I in yes I I wish and I I hope
and I pray for the for the cave I think
that the the more fish and cursed
aspects of a quote unquote open mind
haven't been explicated by people or
even recognized that it's seen in this
culture as something that one everyone
should have more of and I think that my
mind has been somewhat too open and I
need to close it and it's not pleasant
to have such an open
mind I'm not saying that as something
yeah yeah that's where the S comes in
that's where you have to have people
that help you
wow because it's not it's not easy to
have an open mind especially when
everyone around us is you know like they
are and that's why S I mean that's why
it's necessary it's not just something
helpful it's
necessary
well well I I'm very much looking
forward to reading that book do you have
a
title right now I'm calling it The
resurrected good because it's it's you
know it's people that have gone through
death in a sense and are now alive
again and so I thought that's they're
resurrected if you enjoyed that clip
then the full podcast is out right now
you can click around here enjoy
subscribe to theories of everything to
get notified of upcoming podcasts as
there are new full length podcasts every
week on the topics of mathematics
physics Consciousness Free Will and
AI